King Records with the economy with jobs
with the most employed today that we've
ever had in the history of our country
we have the best unemployment numbers
that we've had in the history of our
country in some cases 51 years but
generally in the history of our country
companies are moving back in things are
going well and I said let's have the
meeting on infrastructure we'll get that
done easily that's one of the easy ones
and instead of walking in happily into a
meeting I walk in to look at people that
had just said that I was doing the cover
up I don't do cover-ups you people know
that probably better than anybody and I
was just looking at a list of some of
the things that we just did more than
2500 subpoenas qualified for and I let
everybody talk I let the White House
Counsel speak for 30 hours 30 hours I
have 19 special counsel lawyers 40 FBI
agents I said open it all up let them
have whatever they want
nearly 500 search warrants think of that
a search warrant did you ever see a
search warrant before neither did I this
was over 500 search warrants and of the
19 people that were heading up this
investigation or whatever you want to
call it with Bob Butler
they were contributors to the Democrat
Party most of them into Hillary Clinton
they hated President Trump they hated
him with a passion they went to her big
party after the election that turned out
to be awake not a party was awake and
they were very angry these are the
people that after two years and 40
million or 35 million dollars it'll end
up being a lot more than that by the
time all the bills are paid this is what
happened no collusion no obstruction no
nothing they issued
50 orders authorizing use of pen
registers think of that though 500
witnesses and then I have Nancy Pelosi
go out and say that the President of the
United States engaged in a cover-up now
we've had a house investigation we have
Senate investigations we have
investigations like nobody has ever had
before and there's nothing we did
nothing wrong they would have loved to
have said we colluded they would have
loved it these people were out to get us
the Republican Party and President Trump
they were out together this was a
one-sided horrible thing the bottom line
is they said there's no collusion no
collusion with Russia you heard so much
talk about phone calls that my son made
to me from this meeting that was set up
by GPS fusion it looks like which is the
other side for those that don't know and
for a year I heard about phone calls
went to a special number unauthorized
and it would have been my son Don who's
a good young man who's gone through hell
and they were calls that must have been
made by him before and after the me 3
calls after massive study at work they
actually found who made the calls one
was a friend of ours a real estate
developer great guy most of you know
nice guy loves our country and the other
one was the head of NASCAR two of them
so of the three calls that were so
horrible that he had a meeting and he
called me and then he had the meeting
after and he made two more calls and
they were written about like this little
little lines couple of lines nobody
wanted to admit it even last night we
had a great election I went there on
Monday we had a
an election for Fred Keller it was a
50/50 shot and he won in a landslide we
went and we did a rally hardly mentioned
today and yet if he lost it would have
been the biggest story in the country
even bigger than this witch hunt stuff
that you guys keep writing about so
here's the bottom line
there was no collusion
there was no obstruction we've been
doing this since I've been president and
actually the crime was committed on the
other side we'll see how that all turns
out I hope it turns out well but to what
to my way of thinking and I know a lot
of you agree with me the crime was
committed on the other side this whole
thing was a takedown attempt at the
President of the United States and
honestly you ought to be ashamed of
yourselves
for the way you report it so dishonestly
not all of you but many of you the way
you reported so I've said from the
beginning right from the beginning that
you probably can't go down two tracks
you can go down the investigation track
and you can go down the investment track
or the track of let's get things done
for the American people I love the
American people drug prices are coming
down first time in 51 years because of
my administration but we can get them
down way lower working with the
Democrats we can solve the problem on
the border in 15 minutes if the
Democrats would give us a few votes so I
just wanted to let you know that I
walked into the room and I told Senator
Schumer speaker Pelosi I want to do
infrastructure I want to do it more than
you want to do it I'd be really good at
that that's what I do but you know what
you can't do it under these
circumstances so get these phony in
está geishas over with the Wall Street
Journal just wrote today just a little
while ago I saw it mr. Malla wasn't
obstructed in any way mr. Wall Street
Journal editorial today mr. Malla wasn't
obstructed in any way his copious report
copious four hundred and thirty four
pages now they want to interview all of
the same people again they want an
interview Jerry Nadler who's been an
enemy of mine for many years he fought
me in New York unsuccessfully by the way
I've had great success against Jerry but
he was representing Manhattan and he
would fight me all the time on the west
side railroads many times very
unsuccessfully he failed I come to
Washington I become president that I
said oh no I have Jerry Nadler again so
Wall Street Journal mr. Miller wasn't
obstructed in any way his copious report
was released for all to see and there
was no collusion this is the Wall Street
Journal and there was no collusion
between Russia and the Trump campaign
that's it but they want to make this a
big deal whether or not they carry the
bigeye word out I can't imagine that but
they probably would because they do
whatever they have to do I'll tell you
there's a danger here if someday a
Democrat becomes president and you have
a Republican house they could impeach
him for any reason or her any reason we
can't allow that to happen we can't
allow it to happen so when you look at
all of the transparency when you look at
all I've done and I will tell you my
lawyers say you don't have to do this
you can use presidential privilege you
don't have to let your lawyers and all
of your staff testify you can use
presidential privilege sir would you
recommend it well you can be transparent
or you can be tight being if you've done
nothing wrong being transparent is
better so I said I did nothing wrong
let's be transparent so that's what you
have
all of these things look at that all of
these things 500 witnesses that I
allowed to testify it's a disgrace so
when they get everything done I'm all
set
- lets get infrastructure
let's get drug prices down in the
meantime we're doing tremendous work
without them we're doing tremendous
executive orders a lot of work we've had
a great success most successful economy
perhaps in our country's history we've
cut regulations at a level that nobody
else has cut him before the largest tax
cut in the history of the country so
we're doing a lot of work Steve here
because this meeting was set up a number
of days ago at 11 o'clock all of a
sudden I hear last night they're gonna
have a meeting right before this meeting
to talk about the I word the I word can
you imagine I don't speak to Russians
about campaigns when I went to Wisconsin
and Michigan and Pennsylvania I don't
say oh let's call Russia maybe they can
it's a hoax the greatest hoax in history
I respect the courts I respect Congress
I respect right here was where we're
standing but what they've done is abuse
this is investigation number for the
same thing probably five and it really
started I think pretty much from the
time we came down the escalator in Trump
Tower so I say to you that we're going
to get everything done we're doing a lot
without them let them play their games
we're going to go down one track at a
time let them finish up and we'll be all
set thank you everybody